This is RStudio, it's an IDE or an Integrated
Development Environment and it's what we'll be using to create
R scripts and to create plots. It's a point and
click system that organizes our workspace and it has some
nice features for creating and sharing work. Here's a basic
tour of it. The main interface contains four panels that
can be resized as needed. Now, you may only see
three panels when you open RStudio. If so, just open
a new R script by clicking on the file, and then
New File > R Script. So, in the top left here, we
have R scripts. These are the files in which we will type
our R commands. We'll also save these files, so we can alter
them or share them at a later time. In the bottom
left, we have the R Console. You can type in R
commands here. However, these R commands will only be saved in
a temporary history. The commands won't be saved to a file like
up in here that can be reviewed at a later
date. In the top right of RStudio, we have two
tabs. One called Environment and one called History. The Environment will
contain all the objects, functions and values that are in the
current working memory for R. History on the other hand
will keep a running log of any of the R commands
that we run. Now we can run R scripts directly from
our files but we can also type them into the console.
No matter which way we type them in the History will
capture them. And finally, in the lower right, we have the
Files, Plots, Packages, Help and Viewer section. You'll learn more about
these later but this is where our plots or graphs will
first appear when we run an R command that creates a
visualization. Now that we've gone over the layout of RStudio,
I want you to match some actions that you might do
in each panel of R. Remember this first panel is for
R files or R scripts. This second area is for the
workspace or the history. This third space is the Console where
we get our output. And this fourth panel is for Files,
Packages, Plots, and Help. So for example, if I asked you
to match the activity to one of these panels, like
save an R script that would correspond to box number one.
You can save them by clicking on this button. Now we
could of course use the main menu, but I'm actually include
as any one of your options here. The main purpose of this quiz is
just to get you familiar with RStudio. So here are your list of actions.
And I want you to pair it with the panel where you would do it
in RStudio. Put the number of the corresponding panel in each of the boxes.